well speaking of adults and moms more
than 25 million American mothers work
outside the home now there's a new push
to find jobs that work for their home
life
a recent motherhood in America survey
found 34 percent of women did not go
back to work after having their babies
the mom project is a Chicago based
startup that's trying to lower that
number
it connects moms with employers who will
work with them to keep them on the job
Allyson Robinson founded the mom project
while she was on maternity leave
it works with seventy-five thousand job
seekers and more than one thousand
companies worldwide Allyson Robinson is
with us this morning good morning good
morning so I'm sure there are a lot of
barriers but what are some of the
biggest barriers preventing moms from
going back into the workforce after
having their kids
I think first is the high cost of
childcare the average childcare costs in
the u.s. ranges around eight to ten
thousand which is a significant
percentage of many take-home earnings
right so that continues to be one second
is in flexible work arrangements I think
many companies still very much reward in
office work culture which can be
particularly punishing to working
families and the third is a lack of
policies to really support working
families in the u.s. particularly our
lack of national paid parental leave
which is a global issue more than one of
the few countries in the Western world
that don't have policies to support
parents particularly the early years of
life and then also support child care as
you match families with companies that
might support the lifestyle they want to
lead as parents it's a lifestyle yeah
what are some of the policies you're
looking for in companies that really
support parents yeah so certainly
benefits companies that offer childcare
subsidies that can help alleviate that
burden is really important and family
family leave is very important
infertility benefits maternal health
benefits are all really really important
I would say more the most important
thing is really respect we find so many
users on our platform just don't feel
respected at work so we're really
looking for the companies that we work
what that we partner with to really
respect the individuals that they're
bringing into the work force and don't
just talk about diversity and inclusion
but really live those values every day
that's so important because you know
it's not just policies that companies
have
that can really help women balance work
and life but it's also those subtle
things like respect women feeling valued
even if they may not have as much time
as they used to what how do you vet
companies in terms of how supportive
they will be of mothers especially when
you can't necessarily measure things
like respect yeah so the companies that
we seek out really have made public
commitments to diversity and inclusion
and many of the companies that we work
with actually come to us and they're
really champions of diversity inclusion
in the u.s. of over 350 executives have
signed a pledge to support diversity
inclusion and so they're really
companies that respect working families
and put their money where their mouth is
when it comes to supporting them I
presume this is more than a charitable
act for companies though I mean they
recognize that you put a mom into a
position there are skills that transfer
from one area of life to another and
people with broader and more interesting
and varied life experiences do a better
job at the office absolutely yes
diversity is really shifted from being a
social topic to a business imperative
companies that are diverse financially
outperform their more homogeneous peers
so really this topic has shifted to a
business imperative company executives
it's something that their scorecard in
looking at very closely but they're
really struggling to put that commitment
into practice and so the mom project has
been a really great solution for them to
put action against that those goals what
is the most important thing you think a
mom out there needs to know about trying
to get back into the workforce yeah so I
think it's really important to stay
relevant so many women think about the
cost of childcare versus what they might
be earning and the math isn't breaking
in their favor know that when you take a
step out of the workforce it's really
important that you're able to
demonstrate those skills that you are
gaining how whether it be through
volunteer work and really show how your
skills are relevant refresh your skills
for today's economy and really shine
with confidence it's a very tightened
job market today is a great time to be a
job seeker and so go in with confidence
you've been raising your children that's
very important work it's not just having
the baby and going back to work maybe
six months later this is you've been
away for years and thus you have to get
more on top of things
exactly
great stuff it's really great stuff and
really important stuff as well I mean
it's one generation of workers but it's
the next generation of workers as well
it really is yes I just read 10,000 baby
boomers are retiring every day in the US
so the the future of the workforce is
gonna look very diverse Allison thank
you so much Allison thank you very much
we appreciate it